et pour revenir sur la réforme des
retraites nous accueillons monsieur
olivier thériault représentant du
personnel cgt bus ratp bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
on avait une première semaine plutôt
houleuse à l'assemblée nationale avec
des débats qui était très tendue qu'est
ce que vous retenez justement de cette
première semaine de débats ce que je
retiens c'est que quand des
parlementaires mettent en difficulté la
majorité
on voit bien que les débats vole pas
très haut en fait quoi sur la partie
technique sur la leur capacité à
vraiment exprimé sur la forme sur le
fond en fait à quoi sert cette réforme
ils sont voilà il n'y arrive pas du tout
et c'est un bon relais dans la période
de pouvoir compter sur des
parlementaires quelque obédience qu'il
soit mais généralement des forces
progressistes c'est quand même
voilà c'est une période qui nous permet
nous aussi de continuer à nous organiser
ces démonstrations qui montre bien que
c'est pas que le prolétariat qui qui
s'insurgent mais aussi des personnes
alors je vais pas dire un peu plus
éclairés parce que sinon ça veut dire qu
on s'insulte aurait nous mêmes mais en
tout cas qu'ils ont l'habitude de
traiter les dossiers
et voilà donc ça nous confirme en tout
cas qu'on ne se trompe pas dans ce
combat et que les français dans leur
majorité ont raison de soutenir
l'ensemble des démarches qui sont faites
pour faire tomber cette réforme ingrate
alors vous avez parlé d'une période qui
vous permet de vous justement de vous
organiser on a vu plusieurs
mobilisations récemment que ce soit la
ratp la sncf ou d'autres corps de
métiers pour demander le retrait de
cette réforme
cela n'a abouti à rien on sait qu'il ya
également la conférence de financement
comment est ce que vous allez justement
vous mobiliser dans les prochains jours
bon de toute façon des face à une
majorité qui a la tête dure
donc évidemment qu'on va continuer à
s'organiser on va pas alors il ya un
appel de l'intersyndicale
pour le 31 la stratégie des journées
comme ça pas là c'est une fois dans la
semaine ne fonctionnera pas et ça c'est
une prise de conscience je pense de tout
le monde
par contre c'est pas opposable à ce que
l'on s'organise dans les différents
corps de métiers et notamment on voit
que les avocats continuent à nous à la
ratp par exemple aujourd'hui nous sommes
sur un aspect très très grave qui est la
répression syndicale ou sur le dépôt de
vitry sur les dépôts de fleurs nous
avons des camarades de la cgt qui sont
attaqués en disciplinaire pouvant aller
jusqu'à la révocation pour des faits de
grève il faut dire la vérité c'est sur
des faits de grève
après on constitue des dossiers pour
pour biaiser un petit peu le débat mais
on leur reproche en fait d'avoir été des
meneurs des meneurs de la grève et dans
ceux parmi ses collègues et notamment le
collègue françois qui a tenté à essayer
en tout cas on attend à ses jours il a
fait une tentative de suicide il ya pas
très longtemps et en consultant son
dossier disciplinaire on s'est rendu
compte que aujourd'hui ils veulent
vraiment le révoquer ils veulent
vraiment le faire partir de l'entreprise
après vingt ans de loyaux services
tout simplement par avoir été un des
meneurs de la grève sur le dépôt de
vitry et à cette occasion nous est la
cgt bus ratp
nous appelons d'ores et déjà à
manifester à être en grève le 5 et 6 sur
ces aspects disciplinaires parce que
justement la ratp plus que d'ailleurs la
sncf dans cette histoire a la ratp
jouent vraiment le bras armé du
gouvernement et appliquent à la lettre
la politique macro nist alors on sait
que la prochaine réunion sur la
conférence de financement est prévu le
10 mars
la cgt doit d'ailleurs débattre demain
de son maintien ou non au sein de cette
conférence
quelle posture doigts
voilà doit prendre doit adopter votre
syndicat votre avis je suis un peu mal
placé pour donner des ordres à mon
syndicat toutefois je pense que quand
y'a rien à négocier a rien à négocier
quoi on sait exactement ce qu'il faut
faire
on va pas se raconter d'histoires sur le
fait que le financement de toute façon
ce n'est pas à nous de payer le
financement de la retraite c'est plutôt
à ceux qui utilisent notre force de
travail qui nous qui se paye sur notre
santé sauf qu'on voit bien que toutes
les les différentes mesures qui sont
prises depuis quelques temps sont faites
pour que le patronat se dégager
complètement de tout ce qui est
financement des systèmes solidaires donc
si on veut vraiment financer une
retraite et sur les bases de ce qui
existe en avait pas sur le régime par
points
évidemment que ça ne se fera ça ne se
fera pas sur sur le sur le lot des enfin
ça ne doit pas se faire en tout cas sur
le dos des des prolétaires très bien en
tout cas merci beaucoup je voulais juste
enfin juste avant je suis désolé mais je
voulais juste aussi insisté sur un point
parce qu on a du mal an qu'il en parlait
mais la convergence qui est en train de
se faire en ce moment et notamment le 14
mars
on doit pas la laisser passer voilà je
voulais aussi passer un message clair
que 14 mars on voit bien qu'à une
convergence possible gilet jaune et
syndicalistes et non syndiqués
d'ailleurs et voilà moi je lance cet
appel qu il faut il faut continuer à
envoyer les signes positifs d'une
convergence va dire mélanger les
couleurs mais en tout cas les
additionner alors tout cas la
mobilisation continue que ce soit dans
votre secteur ou comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure
du côté des avocats qui manifestent
encore aujourd'hui en tout cas merci
beaucoup
olivier d'orio de nous avoir accordé cet
entretien je rappelle que vous êtes
représentant du personnel cgt bus ratp